- It was literally
everywhere but the toilet.
(upbeat music)
- I worked at a Victoria's
Secret throughout college.
One time, this very sweet
old lady came into the store
and had an accident and
just pooped on the floor.
And my manager had to clean it up,
and Spencer Pratt came in once.
- So, I got a job at the
Express at the Del Amo Mall.
And I keep getting
assigned to the jean wall.
There's a whole method to it,
you have to fold it in threes and then.
So, I'm folding it and
I overhear my coworker
compliment my folding job to my manager,
and I overhear my manager respond, "well,
"you know those Asians are
really good at origami."
- I used to work at a
candle shop in Sydney,
and one day I went to open
the store as I normally would,
and underneath the door was this little
love heart-shaped USB and a note,
so I picked it up and it
said to the girl with the hat
and it was a love letter,
and I put the USB in and
it was a PJ Harvey song,
The Perfect Day, and I
never found out who it was.
- So, in high school,
I worked at Blockbuster
which makes me seem really old,
but it wasn't that long ago.
And this guy would call all
the time asking for porn
and we could tell it was the same guy.
Most of the time, we
would just have to say,
I'm sorry sir, this is a family store,
and his response would be,
"what about this family of sperm?"
And then he would hang up.
- The store was huge and the bathrooms
are in the back of the store.
And there was this wafting smell growing,
and we had gotten so many
complaints from customers
that we're like okay, let's see
what this nonsense is about.
And it was like that movie The Shining
where there's so much
blood all over the place.
Well, just replace all the
redness with brown chunky poo.
- My manager at Abercrombie
was a woman who I think was,
she seemed 20 years older than me,
she was probably three
years older than me.
And the most distinct
thing I remember happening
is one day I was eating
an apple and she said
what does that taste like?
And I said, an apple?
And she said yeah, I've never had one.
She was later arrested, I believe,
for stealing thousands of
dollars worth of clothes
for her nephews.